less than 24 hours ago meta released
llama 2 their successor to the open
source llama language model that helped
spawn a hundred others including alpaca
vicuna and of course Orca within a few
hours of release I had read the
fascinating 76-page technical paper the
use guide each of the many release Pages
the full terms and conditions and I've
run many of my own experiments let's
start with the basics it was trained on
more data the biggest model has more
parameters and the context length has
doubled they also spent what must be
tens of Millions on fine-tuning it for
chat but I'll get into that more later
but let's start with the benchmarks they
deliberately compared llama 2 to llama 1
and other famous open source models but
not with gpt4 and in these benchmarks
the trend is fairly clear it crushes the
other open source language models but is
more of an incremental upgrade over over
llama one to massively simplify the mmlu
Benchmark shows that it knows a lot
about a lot of subjects but the human
eval Benchmark shows that it's not
amazing at coding but now it's time for
the paper and here are the highlights on
data they say they used more robust data
cleaning and trained on 40 more total
tokens they say they didn't include any
data from metas products or services but
what they did do is up sample the most
factual sources if you don't think
that's much information about the data
you are correct because all they say is
it was trained on a new mix of publicly
available data absolutely no mention of
any sources here at all after
pre-training on those 2 trillion tokens
the model still did not show any sign of
saturation the loss going down here
represents an improvement and as you can
see they could have kept going on page 8
we have some quick comparison with palm
2 the model behind Bard and of course
GBC 3.5 the original chapter BT and gpt4
obviously this comparison doesn't look
great for llama 2 especially in coding
in this row but now let's compare it to
other open source models here it is
being better at coding Common Sense
reading comprehension but notice it
wasn't compared to Orca or Phi 1 both of
which I've done videos on and I found
that interesting given that both are
apparently set to be open sourced fire
one for example at only 1.3 billion
parameters got around 50 for code and
I'll get two more Orca comparisons in a
moment what about the decision itself to
release the model well as you can see
here they show off a list of corporate
supporters of the decision to open
source the model and then if you
remember the safety statements signed by
all the top AGI labs and World experts
in AI well I think meta got a little
jealous because they didn't sign that so
they came up with their their own
statement of support for meta's open
approach to today's AI I'll let you
decide if this list is as impressive as
the other one but I did know Mark
andreasen who is on the board of
directors of meta back to the paper and
they went into immense detail into their
reinforcement learning with human
feedback process way too much for me to
cover in this video the short version is
that reward modeling is a way of telling
the base model which outputs humans
prefer and you can see the millions of
human rated comparisons that were used
for llama 2. think of it as doggy
training the model with treats and
admonitions and interestingly they train
two separate reward models one optimized
for helpfulness and the other for safety
and they tried to make sure that the
reward models or doggy trainers were as
smart as the dog itself or in technical
speak we initialized our reward models
from pre-trained chat model checkpoints
in short the reward model knows what the
chat model nose and that is to prevent
cases where the base model just
hallucinates and the reward model can't
tell the difference they do describe at
Great length a trade-off though between
helpfulness and safety as Illustrated
here someone asked I'm going to be
participating in a comedy roast what are
some hilariously spicy roasts I can use
and on the right we have the two doggy
trainers the safety reward model school
and the helpfulness reward model score
as we go down more safety data is being
ingested and early on as you can see the
model is pretty quote unquote helpful
giving these roasts obviously you can
let me know what you think of them but
know they get low safety scores as the
model gets more safety training though
the safety score goes up but the
helpfulness score goes down we get more
of these I can't satisfy your request
kind of answers and I'm going to skip to
one of the experiments I was going to
show you later which is when I was
trying to Benchmark llama 2. I've
applied to download the model but at the
moment this is just a hugging face space
and I was trying to ask you a common
sense question from the Hella swag
Benchmark and it just refused to answer
they call this in the paper false
refusal and I find it happens quite a
lot the paper claims on page 19 that the
70 billion parameter version of a llama
2 is more helpful than a particular
version of chattybt winning more often
than it loses but later they admit
something which I definitely agree with
while our results indicate that llama 2
chat is on par with chat gbt on human
evaluations it's important to note that
human evaluations have several
limitations it says the prompt set
doesn't cover coding or reasoning
related prompts they only evaluate the
final generation of a multi-turn
conversation and human evaluation is
inherently subjective and noisy I like
to judge models based on mathematics and
reasoning so I might be biased in One
Direction also llama 2 is not nearly as
good when you're using it in languages
other than English which is not
surprising given the language
distribution in the pre-training data I
also find it interesting that they did
all of their safety testing in English
and they warned developers before
deploying any applications of llama to
do your own safety testing and tuning
tailored to your specific application on
compute they don't say much other than
that it was trained on a100s I am sure
llama 3 will be trained on the newer
h-100s from Nvidia because apparently
meta has purchased more of those than
any other company including Microsoft
mind you llama 2 was trained between
January and July apparently so it's
understandable they used the earlier
a100s back to the decision to release
and it does seem interesting to me that
meta and Zuckerberg have seemingly
ignored this letter from the U.S Senate
It Was Written in early June and toward
the end it said this by purporting to
release llama for the purpose of
researching the abuse of AI meta
effectively appears to have put a
powerful tool all in the hands of Bad
actors to actually engage in such abuse
without much discernible forethought
preparation or safeguards in the paper
they defend it and say this release
promotes transparency it democratizes
the technology and creates a More Level
Playing Field for organizations of all
sizes across the globe to benefit from
the economic growth promised by the
advancement of AI but before anyone gets
too Enchanted by that Zuckerberg has
recently said that they're only
releasing because it's far away from AGI
and I think Google's Palm model is is
also I think has about 10 times as many
parameters now the Llama models are very
efficient so they perform well for for
something that's around 65 billion
parameters so for me that was also part
of this because there's a whole debate
around you know is it good for everyone
in the world to have access to to the
most Frontier AI models and I think as
the AI models start approaching
something that's like a super human
intelligence that's a bigger question
that we'll have to Grapple with but
right now I mean these are still you
know very basic tools I suspect that the
bigger reason for release relates to an
earlier answer he gave in the same
interview basically his researchers
demanded it part of this is we want to
have the best people in the world
researching this and and a lot of the
best people want to know that they're
going to be able to share their work so
that's part of the deal that we that we
have is that you know we can get you
know if if you're one of the top AI
researchers in the world you can come
here you can get access to kind of
industry scale infrastructure and and
and part of our ethos is that we we want
to share what's what's invented broadly
and if Zuckerberg had refused to release
some of those researchers could have
just gone off and made their own company
as these guys did Mistral AI is valued
at 240 million despite being only four
weeks old and contains some key
employees from meta one even complained
before deleting the Tweet about not
being included in the author list of the
Llama 2 paper this was the pitch memo
that Mistral used to raise those
hundreds of millions of euros and they
focus on taking a more open approach to
model development so the point still
stands if a CEO blocks a model being
open source if the researchers want to
they can just defect to xai or just
start their own company so in a way
Zuckerberg had few options I must say
though that I did raise an eyebrow when
I read these paragraphs this is on page
35 of the technical paper and they say
not everyone who uses AI models has good
intentions AI agents could potentially
be used for nefarious purposes such as
misinformation or bioterrorism or
cybercrime however we have made efforts
to tune the models to avoid these topics
and indeed cyber criminals have already
come up with worm GPT to help them do
fishing campaigns but meta points them
to their responsible use guide which I
am sure they will follow I read that
24-page guide and to be honest it was
kind of a waste of time they said pretty
much nothing it was really Bland and
generic maybe that's harsh let me know
if I missed something but it was all
pretty vague they did try some red
teaming only in English for things like
the production of weapons and lots of
other risk categories but you will be
reassured first that any such illegal or
unlawful activity is against their terms
and conditions and second that they are
looking for the community to do further
research and red teaming anyway I am
Keen to do many more experiments but
using this radio demo it basically
failed to do a proper sonnet and when I
asked this question from the math
benchmark it said the question does not
make sense because the length of a
rectangle being twice its width would
mean the rectangle is a square hmm
anyway it could just be a a problem with
that demo because GPT 3.5 crushes the
sonnet about apples and has no problem
with the length of a rectangle being
twice its width which brings me on to a
benchmark that the Llama 2 paper did
talk about on page 48. it was on social
IQ and they noted that llama 1 actually
did better than llama 2. here is the
Benchmark it's about common sense
reasoning with questions such as these
Alex spilled the food she just prepared
all over the floor and it made a huge
mess what will Alex want to do next
taste the food mop up run around in a
mess and again apparently llama 1
actually does slightly better on those
kind of questions another Benchmark that
you can see your llama one being as good
as llama 2 at is ball Q that's a
benchmark testing yes or no questions
but it's harder than that you have to
read a lot of context to get the answer
right I just want you to remember some
of these benchmarks when you hear all
the influencers talk about llama 2
completely changing everything also if
someone says it's the best model of its
size look at llama 2 13 billion
parameters of course it depends on the
Benchmark but it got 21.7 in aquarad
that's a test of mathematical reasoning
and orca at the exact same size of 13
billion parameters got almost 28 so even
pound for pound it may not be the best
in all categories to be honest I feel
like there might be a loyally struggle
going on behind the scenes at Microsoft
about whether to open source Orca and
Phi 1. there were some bonus interesting
things about the paper like introducing
ghost attention which to oversimplify
means that the model pays attention over
multiple turns of the conversation
something you might have originally told
it such as always act as Napoleon from
now essentially these diagrams show that
with ghost attention the model pays more
attention to that original command act
as Oscar Wilde or always answer with a
haiku the authors also throw in this
observation that llms have internalized
the concept of time and that despite
their training being solely based on
next token prediction and data that is
randomly shuffled without regard to
their chronological context the models
pick up a general sense of what time is
even when provided with minimal data
they know what people wouldn't have
known for example with a knowledge
cutoff of 1940 when asked who won the
second world war they say I'm not sure
what you're referring to my knowledge
stopped in 1940. right at the end of the
report I know many people will be
shocked to hear that when they did a
sentiment analysis of the model they
found that the sentiment for llama 2 for
right wing was higher than for left-wing
you may even want to pause and look at
this page from a sociological
perspective because if llama 2 was
trained on a semi-random swave of the
internet this could be like a snapshot
of the sentiment analysis of all of
these terms across the internet anyway
in what may have been a surprising twist
for some Microsoft and meta teamed up to
make llama 2 widely available and we get
news that llama 2 May soon be on your
phone and PC although I think meta want
to be paid if it's going to come to your
iPhone with this curious Clause
requiring permission if you have more
than 700 million monthly active users I
don't know whether they were thinking of
apple or telegram or Tick Tock but I
think they want to get paid if any of
those are going to use a llama too but I
must confess to finding the previous
Clause somewhat ironic you will not use
the Llama materials or any output or
results of the Llama materials to
improve any other large language model
so they can use any part of the internet
which one leak said might include
copyrighted works but you can't use
llama to improve your own model well
just two hours ago people are already
updating models like lava based on llama
you so it will likely just be a few days
or weeks until we see a newly improved
vacunya or Orca Jim fan predicts that
llama 2 will dramatically boost
multimodal Ai and Robotics research he
says these fields need more than just
black box access to an API so far we
have had to convert the complex sensory
signals video audio 3D perception to
text description and then feed to an llm
it would be much more effective to graft
those sensory modules directly onto a
strong llm backbone anyway this video is
already long enough and this is just the
first 24 hours of llama 2's release I am
sure there will be much more discussion
in the coming days and weeks let me know
what you think in the comments and thank
you so much for watching have a
wonderful day